dans les allées de ce magasin Tibo oueri
finalise son menu le mélange des saveurs
et la mise en avant des aliments reste
la priorité du jeune candidat français
au championnat du monde des cuisiniers
je suis plutôt minimaliste en fait dans
mes associations de saveurs je trouve
que le mérite d'un cuisinier c'est de
partir d'une pomme de terre ou d'une
carotte et d'en faire quelque chose de
bon quoi sans je suis pas fan des
associations exotiqu ou dire on a mis du
chocolat pour mettre du chocolat pour
moi ça pas de sens lors de la finale du
bocus d'or le jury observera tout à la
loupe du choix des produits au marché au
gaspillage en cuisine en passant par la
complicité entre thbau roueri et sa
comie Julie Lumeau une fois le Cadie
rempli départ pour l'atelier le chef de
l'école Le Nôtre de plaisir se met pour
la première fois dans les conditions du
concours au menu de la finale la
préparation de 14 assiettes de turbo et
un grand plat de bœuf qui doivent
rappeler la France le tout en 5h3 on va
mouiller la chemise donc on va faire un
service
traiteur va falloir envoyer 30 couves
donc donc dresser dresser remter en
température malgré l'agitation qui règne
dans l'atelier le meug vois de 30 ans
reste
imperturbableib c'est quelqu'un qui
subit rarement l'émotion donc
automatiquement
je le fait qu'il y a beaucoup de chef
qui va être présent beaucoup de bruit
beaucoup de lumière c'est pas un
problème Tiberi a découvert la cuisine à
l'âge de 11 ans en inventant comme il
l'appelle son gâteau poubelle à base de
4/4 celui qui milite pour une cuisine
improvisée aime prendre des risques et
fait revenir ses filets de turbo à la
poêle chaque geste est précis étudié
pour que le plat devienne une œuvre
d'art et après 1 heure et de de travail
le turbo à la grenoubloise se révèle
être un feu d'artifice de saveur j'aime
bien la répartition des saveurs ouais
j'aime bien je trouve que les trois on a
du rassurant on a de du caramélisé un
peu doux et on a du bouillon très léger
un peu boisé avec la truffe ça ça me
plaît beaucoup rendez-vous le 30 janvier
pour la version
finale